Imagine you are an investigation officer and
you need to find the criminal in the case
assigned to you.
You are given samples of blood obtained from
the crime scene and have three suspects in
the list.
How will you find out which suspect is the criminal?
And the case doesn’t end here!
Simultaneously, you have to hand over the
little kid of the victim to one of the two
men claiming to be the child’s father.
How will you solve both the mysteries together?
There is one solution for both the problems
and it’s called “DNA fingerprinting”.
This technique is very crucial in terms of
advancement in modern science and technology.
It is a technique that helps us analyse our
unique DNA just like the unique fingerprints
that we have!
The profiles at the end help us analyse the
DNA of every individual.
For instance, looking at the results of the
first part, we can be almost be sure that
suspect 2 is the criminal.
And similarly, in the second part, we can
say that individual 1 is the biological father
of the child.
Does every person really have a unique DNA?
Of course yes!
DNA is termed as the “Blueprint of life”.
It is a specific set of instructions that
gives rise to the characters that are seen
in the organisms.
But this is something that we are aware of
today and it wasn’t known back then!
So who discovered that DNA is so important?
Which scientist or scientists contributed
towards finding out that DNA is the code for
all the characteristics in us?
Let us find that out by going back in time!
Firstly, let us have a look at the milestones
in this journey.
To begin with, we have the father of genetics,
Gregor Mendel, who introduced the concept
of Heredity to us!
He was the first to hypothesize that there
are “FACTORS” which pass from parents
to offsprings.
This was around mid 1860s.
However, his work was largely ignored.
It was around the first decade of the 20th
century that the two scientists came up with
the theory which helped prove Mendelian genetics.
Who were the two scientists?
They were Walter Sutton and Theodor Boveri.
They put forth the chromosomal theory of inheritance
which helped shine some light on the long
ignored work of Gregor Mendel.
However, Sutton and Boveri’s work gained
better acceptance with the next milestone
which was achieved by the father of experimental
genetics: Thomas Morgan.
Morgan’s work on the little fruit fly was
very instrumental in proving the fact that
“genes are located on the chromosomes”.
His experiments helped explain the location
of eye colour genes on the “X” chromosomes
in Drosophila melanogaster.
We have seen the history of genetics until this time!
Now it’s time we move a step ahead in the timeline!
Until this time, scientists believed that
genes, which are the units of heredity, are
majorly made up of proteins.
In other words, the chemical nature of the
genetic material was thought to be Proteins.
However, this wasn’t really considered to be a fact.
It was just an ASSUMPTION.
People were still trying to figure out what
exactly could the genetic material be made
up of!
It was around 1928 that a breakthrough was
achieved in this field.
A British bacteriologist named Fredrick Griffith
reported for the first time that tiny organisms
like the bacteria are also capable of transferring
genetic information.
His famous “Transformation” experiment
ignited the curiosity regarding genetic material.
A few years later, around 1944, three scientists
named Avery, MacLeod and McCarty figured out
that the transformation principle, or the
unit of heredity to be precise, is actually
DNA.
And this was strongly supported by the work
of Hershey and Chase later around the year
1952.
The simple experiment by these two helped
prove that it is DNA and not the proteins
that form the core of the genetic material.
Later, the structure of DNA, built by the
efforts of Franklin, Watson and Crick formed
a strong foundation for modern day genetics.
This timeline helps us with the milestones
achieved so far in genetics.
Let us have a detailed look at each of these
experiments and events in the upcoming parts!